Turkey has been debated here in this  country widely you know changing  directions shifting access turning its  back to the Western values and I think  there are a lot of prejudices in this  and in this society actually in this  land of big thinking there is no place  for such prejudices so what I can tell  you the treaty represents an enormous  they I think important synthesis of  Islam modernity secularism free-market  economy and all its connections to the  west there is a sense synthesis out of  this which no other Muslim country the  other 57 I respect them all but has  managed to do it so Turkey this turkey  this great synthesis is an ally and a  friend of the spread country